presence means being sensible thinking
carefully through what will this mean
for the community what will it mean for
the next generation see what the West is
really done is robbed its children as
grandchildren and the things that we've
taken for granted I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report as long as
you're here don't forget to click that
little subscribe button and tap that
Bell over there so that you actually see
our videos crazy I know all right
joining me today is the former Deputy
Prime Minister of Australia a relentless
fighter for freedom and the host of
conversations with John John Anderson
welcome to the Rubin report gradually
we're done it really is I am very happy
to have you here because I'll start by
saying that something that I'd never
have told you in person even though
we've met a couple times you reached out
to me about three years ago right when
we built this studio and the show was
taken off there was a nice little bump
in what we were doing and you reached
out to me or your people reached out to
me and said John Anderson former Deputy
Prime Minister of Australia would like
to chat with you he's coming to LA and
it was really the first time that I
thought whoa this thing is seriously
international that the conversations
that I'm having are seriously important
and we had a great breakfast where we
talked about freedom and we do
conversation and all of those things and
since we've done a couple of ents
together so I guess my first question is
you've been in this fight for a long
time
when did you start becoming aware that
there was something worldwide around
having decent conversations that was
sort of becoming the new way of going
about discourse well in my initial sort
of concerns around freedom were largely
economic so I was part of the coalition
government in Australia from 1996 to
2007 and we were a reforming government
our emphasis on freedom was economic
freedom so that we would not pass on
debt burdens and lack of opportunities
to young people and that was my focus I
think for me it was after the great
financial crisis and you saw the blame
game started to really play out and I
started to see that we needed to make
major adjustments to the way we run our
he's in the West they're all hopelessly
indebted with the exception of a few
places like Australia but we wouldn't do
it we wouldn't own what we're done and
he started to see the shouting become
very shrill now it hadn't started then
but you asked when I started to realize
this is a real problem it was about that
point because I started to see that that
actually understood properly in
democracies governments downstream of
culture mm-hmm and so's economics and
the whole Lehman Brothers collapse was
about a collapsing standards but again
you didn't have a grappling with what
had gone on in terms of the ethics of it
bankers instead of saying what should I
do
how should I behave rather what can I
get away with how can I build a bigger
bundle for me and for those around me
and hang you know the people who bank
with us and who trusted us and rely on
us I thought and I started to think this
is getting really serious but then it
was the nature of the debate because it
wasn't a debate anymore yeah now you
can't get good public policy without a
good debate and you can't have a good
debate without a reasonable degree of
respect for the other person whose
dignity and standing so it's interesting
because I was a struggling stand-up when
Lehman Brothers crash and I used to work
at a comedy club handing out tickets in
Times Square right on the corner I think
it was it was either 50th or 51st and
Broadway that's where the Lehman
Brothers Building was this huge lit up
you know massive digital display
building and I remember when it when it
went down it seems like another lifetime
ago but what's it like to be one of the
guys going hey everybody we're about to
go off a cliff here I mean that's that's
not what politicians want to do they
want to always give everybody all the
things that they want out of the problem
yeah yeah there is no doubt we need to
understand that a lot of this rots
started in the 1960s we gave up talking
about you know the big sort of
meta-narratives
Who am I what am I where do I fit how
does the world work it's all too hard
and you can understand that in a way
we've seen horrific wars would say in
the Great Depression let's live for us
now mm-hmm and in an age of cheap credit
we started to rack up debt right across
the Western world you know it's not as
if I'm singling out one country you
country or my country we're all into who
we poured down it hold on yeah and and
here's the rap in a democracy so you can
say to mr. congressman now listen I'll
give you my vote if you promise me X Y
or Z and mr. congressman might know
instinctively he knows e stuff you
wonder how many of them well I shouldn't
single out American come right a lot of
politicians well they know as much as
they should
yeah they might rift over on us say look
that it's not a good way to do it we
can't afford it it'll come against your
children and your grandchildren unfunded
liabilities if it turned out to be a
nightmare but we've said no no you don't
get over all right I'll give it to you
because it's on the never never and
kings from of old of known that until
the credit runs out you could live
pretty well but when the credit does run
out it's a very different story
so it really I think it has its genesis
in the 60s and this idea that it's all
about me I will do what I like with my
life etc cetera cetera we abandoned the
golden rule do unto others as you'd have
them do unto you it's all about me now
cuz most people don't live like that but
that became a sort of prevailing ethos
right we would never live like that in
our own lives right I mean sometimes you
do well most of us have been in debt at
some point I racked up too much credit
card stuff or whatever it is but you
would never just well you can't I mean
that's the thing as an individual you
can keep just getting more credit as you
keep not paying things but somehow in
government's we seem to be able to do
that well I think that you know it takes
two to tango
I think the electorate the voters if you
like if demanded too much mm-hmm but
politicians who should have known better
right across the West have not been
prudent enough either and there's an
old-fashioned word called prudence it
was a classic virtue it went along with
integrity and courage and all of those
other ones and prudence disappeared and
the story of Lehman Brothers in many
ways the disappearance of prudence
presence means being sensible thinking
carefully through what will this mean
for the community what will that mean
for the the next generation so what the
West has really done is robbed its
children and it's grandchildren are the
things that we've taken for granted and
and and look I don't know what
privileges because you can adjust it a
thousand ways but as I understand it I
think you and I would buy say we're very
very fortunate people we've grown up in
free society we've
really wanted and and so forth but
though she should never be taken for
granted do you see a direct connection
then between us stop no longer asking
the big questions in the 60s to then
directly to well politicians then just
say here's more here's more here's more
more because because the people no
longer have the tools to understand why
that's actually not good that actually
really explains what's happening here in
America yeah well I do think that I
really do think that I think we are
paying a terrible price as my personal
you for washing out
you see I think for a long time I don't
think in particularly my country was
ever particularly religious but there
was an idea that broadly speaking the
Christian view of the world
love your neighbor Europe accountable to
a higher authority you may dislike your
neighbor but they still have value and
Worth and dignity and I have to respect
that
broadly same is true then it just became
seen as one of main truths
now of course we know there's open
hostility to traditional underlying
beliefs in the West on the part of I
don't know what you call them do you
call them a lot of the Intelligencer of
a politically correct or the people who
have a microphones or the elites
whatever word you want to use is
enormous hostility there says the stuffs
dangerous and you shouldn't expose your
children to it but what's the substitute
what are we putting up instead the idea
of radical autonomy oh my I will take
hazard a guess that you would understand
exactly what I mean if I said to you I
don't think you ever find yourself in
yourself you actually find yourself by
relating to and serving others and being
considerate and in looking to see where
you can make a difference not just for
yourself all the time self-centeredness
just destroys well that's the I guess
real irony of the situation as we've
removed some of these traditional
beliefs we've replaced them with
authoritarian movements they don't seem
to be replaced by freer movements if
there was something so wrong with them
you would think all right well then
freedom will replace them but no it
seems to always go the other way well
very much so I'm a great believer in the
in the freedom so I don't think you've
never run unbundle and we've had a
debate in Australia what's the first
freedom and people say what's obviously
is freedom of speech they say because
that's the one by which you defend all
the other freedoms
but I think I want to join with Frank
furedi now and that's an interesting
story to herself I would be seen as
broadly speaking classic liberals stroke
conservative he would not you know he
was a student radical in the 60s
wonderful delightful man if you've not
had him on no I haven't sure get him
Frank for it Kent University but he
would say if I said to him I did I said
to him do you think freedom of speech
it's the first freedom he said no no no
no he said you should understand with
your Christian convictions that actually
it was freedom of conscience mm-hmm our
forebears were burning one another at
the stake and my grateful cruel
appalling thing to do to another human
being because they had a minority view
and after a while people sort of said
well this isn't very consistent with
Christian charity and it's pretty
barbaric and is stupid because a person
with a minority view today that we burn
at the stake may in fact be part of a
movement that tomorrow do you the
majority do you sense that sort of where
we're heading right now and going yeah
it really worries me there's a there's
an aura of triumphalism I think Douglas
Murray specious is right you've had a
whole series of movements to correct
things that have needed correcting in
the West and by the way what system
delivers the ability to peacefully
correct things that are wrong better
than liberal participate or democracy
and you think of the civil rights
movement and that incredible speech I
look forward to the day when my children
are judged by the content of their
character not the color of their skin so
all of these movements you know I mean I
have three daughters it's incredibly
important to me that they're paid
properly for their work or whatever it
happens to be as Douglas Murray says you
know that train has moved with a lot of
cabooses in its carriage under the
platform it's starting to slow down with
my tremendous progress if you like in
Martin Luther's language those who have
been marginalized and sidelined have
been allowed to join the citizenry
mm-hmm and all of a sudden the Train the
governor's let go and just when you're
getting close to the station it's taken
off so how do you untether people from
that then right so so I
Herr Douglas talk about this I've
discussed it with him but how do you
then untether people from the idea that
they're still oppressed when they're no
longer oppressed
if oppression can be used to control
people that's a pretty addicting feeling
right there well this is the great
problem I think of victimhood politics
now way a good friend of mine from the
left in Australia very noble old classic
sort of Australian socialist and I've
always regarded him as a man of noble
intent and he said you know look we were
about in the labor movement universalism
so if someone was oppressed or sidelined
or not being looked after properly the
idea was to elevate their status so they
were part of the citizenry that's what
Martin Luther King was trying to do in
this country but now we've created a new
caste system a new aristocracy so a
victim often self-proclaimed or say I've
got all these grievances and I'm owed
and I need those addressed and society's
left saying well if we say sorry and try
and make them I hope you'll appreciate
it but no they'll say we were owed hmm
if you don't then you confirm that
victimhood and you're a hater or a
racist or or whatever but here's the rub
if your power comes from being a victim
you have every interest in ensuring that
your victim hood is never address that
you remain a victim and that's why you
can't untether it from that train well I
actually cannot say to you I think this
is proving to be such an unsatisfactory
philosophy for people who find
themselves you know the rush for a
university student oh I'm a victim i
moan but as i think it through i think
and you and i've seen this i think
there's a lot of people realizing that's
not very sustaining and in the end i
don't want to be a victim i want to be a
full member of a community and i want to
pull my weight and we've got a plight of
the better angels isn't it funny that we
know in in real life when you're around
friends or family people that you
socialize with nobody wants to be around
a victim nobody wants to be around
someone endlessly complaining on them
you want to be around people that that
impress you that inspire you that make
you laugh that have joy in the world
that can share something good with you
and yet somehow a movement has been
created that somehow seems sexy based on
something that is so anti how any of us
if we really thought about our lives
would ever really want to be a let's
let's be clear I think you and I would
agree on this there are people who have
very legitimate absolutely the paper
animal is a Peking was talking about if
I can say this in your country is
somebody who's not American I mean those
grievances were deep and real a roar and
horrible for anybody has studied Jimmy
crow and what happened and then it's
extraordinary yeah I hope you don't mind
me saying that no no of court well your
is it you're saying you're saying you
cuz they did I mean the whole point is
to lift yourself out of it and join the
rest of the community I mean the great
again they had need to did I know
everybody talks about it but Kennedy
asked not what your country can do for
you but what you can do for your country
we've reversed it if we reverse the idea
of citizenship so now we say I demand my
country meet my needs but as you say you
know how to stay there one of the most
remarkable men in Australia he's just
retired he's a very old man now that was
the man Frank Lowy behind at Westfield I
see them even here in America shopping
centers huh yeah we've got one right
here now his whole family he escaped the
Holocaust but his family was wiped out
he was a little boy one day
what's his father go after work and he
never came back and he talks about how
he sat in the window day after day after
day set by the window waiting for dad to
come home dad never did geez
and the whole Holocaust thing oh that
was appalling I mean how any human being
could do what the Nazis did to other
human beings is beyond my comprehension
but if a man like that had spent the
rest of his life saying I am a victim
I'm Oh fix up my victimhood now I feel
deeply for what he went through but I
respect him hugely for sake I'm not
going to play the victim card and he's
gone out and created jobs for goodness
only knows how many Australians I see
shopping centers here in America and say
oh it's been a success story and we can
sympathize with what he went through but
we can delight in the fact that he has
chosen to be a positive for looking
person and if you like has confronted
those demons by rising above them and
denying them oxygen if I can put it that
way yeah so that's before we go too far
down the political rabbit hole
because I can sense where the richness
of this conversation is I just want to
talk about your story a little bit you
you come from a sixth generation farming
family and somehow went into politics
can you explain a little bit of that
yeah Scottish ancestry which is very
common in rural Australia and in rural
Australia farming and grazing was the
way to go
it's a rough country to farming because
of the unreliable climate Scots were
very good at it because they got this
poor my end and a rough line and so you
know my family's home I regard if I've
done one brilliant thing I chose my
parents move good move and you know the
thing is that so I've been very
fortunate I've seen them go through a
terrible ups and downs my family was
decimated by both the first and second
world war because Australia was deeply
integrated in both double a number of
Australians died in the first world wars
did Americans it was extraordinary the
level of engagement it international
fears that Australia's taken up even
when it was very young but yeah I am now
I went to school and University in
Sydney and I had never contemplated a
political career all those always
fascinated by the great debates and a
voice in our society as a result of
fierce debates that are not personalised
at the best you know where the result of
a clash of great ideas look at the
debates and went into the independence
of America the thinking the depth of
understanding the belief in the Worth
and dignity of all which is where your
freedom motive my belief comes from in
this country but I was literally head
hunted by a retiring federal member at
the precocious age of 27 he said I'm
going to return I think you should ever
go on my place and I said well that's ER
and what had he seen you if you were
coming from a farming family what did he
know about you that he thought this guy
could do it well it's an interesting
question in a way that I can answer it
honestly I'd been at a public meeting
where it said something about he was
from you know the conservative side of
politics he said something about the
left side of politics and I thought he'd
completely missed the point so I stood
up and remonstrate it firmly but not
personally and he actually said to me I
think you should have a go because you
said something
I said something you disagreed with and
you took it up in a good-humoured a
friendly way without attacking me that's
what he actually said to me so and
that's basically what your guiding
principle has been throughout politics
and now even out of politics I mean
you're having conversations Jordan I sat
down with you for your show which was in
front of a live group of people and it
was exactly this it was exactly let's
let's work through this stuff instead of
you know breaking each other's backs
well I just saw us deeply deeply believe
and it stems from my Christian belief
that I'm not it's not for me to judge
others is for me to engage in the
contest of ideas and I all a baloon
passionately in you know in a vigorous
debate you know our Parliament in
Australia is very adversarial mm-hmm and
people often complain about it and I say
look let's split this into its two
components you actually want your
parliamentarians to believe in things
deeply and there ought to be a great
clash over people's versions of how best
to take the place forward what you're
really objecting to I hope it's not that
class of ideas but when it's personal
when people give or take offence I've
just never seen the point of it I've
never seen that it's taken anybody
anywhere do you sense that one side of
the aisle is is better at that than the
other absolutely I think there's a
reason for that like a deep reason for
that yeah dude I think Dantas Murray may
have tapped it again as well and I think
it's getting worse not better a very
clear thinking person from the left said
to me quite recently he said I was quite
deep into my life before I realised
conservatives could be nice people he
said I'm from the left and he just
looked me straight in the eye and he
said John understand there's a little
bit of truth in the old saying that the
right thinks the left is misguided but
the left thinks the right is evil dennis
prager I quoted constantly actually
wasn't he said that do was it not well
I've been quoted that I've been quoting
his quote forever who not yeah no I mean
someone else that said if you and he
might have been reflecting no innocent
okay but I'd note that connection yeah
now there's another person and he said
it to me and then I think you look at
David good hearts work on Briggs and he
brings that out again he says that
families from the left you know will do
almost anything to stop their children
relating to and marrying somebody from
the other side of politics whereas
someone from the conservative and tends
to be quite relaxed and accepting of
somebody of different views and here's
where I think and I don't want to
misrepresent him but I think Douglas
Murray makes the point that in the
current context the lack of logic and
intellectual sort of underpinning for
the positioning that much of the left
now dots on issues means that they have
to demonize others rather than get into
a debate about them well it's pretty
easy if you can just say there are Nazi
yeah that's a lot easier than going into
the philosophical underpinnings of what
you think and then fascinating the way
people bandy the word fascism around no
I studied enough in university on I'm
not a bright bear I don't pretend to be
as I said the only really smart thing I
did was choosing traded parents but but
I do know what a fascist is I do know
its origins and its underpinnings and so
the left pin this table faceted label of
fascism on people in a way that reflects
that they're not interested at all in
any exactitude in language in fact I
would say ambivalence in language has
emerged as the postmodernist best friend
it's becoming very hard to have a debate
not only because of the labels that are
bandied around but the way in which
words no longer mean what they should
mean so our national broadcaster never
stops talking about the importance of
diversity the trouble is they don't
believe in it so they'll make sure that
yes you could go there they've got you
know every gender imagine how many are
they well it depends what time it is
I'll check yeah and if I haven't found
one the fit and I don't want to be
flippant about and I shouldn't be
flippant but in all honesty at you
you'll find what you will find is that
the diversity means anything except
difference in perspectives vertical
perspectives so diversity what does it
really mean now and this is a great
problem very hard to debate when not
only is language used to demonize others
if you used to confuse the argument to
make sure you're not able to talk on the
platform so I know we could probably
spend all days you know talking about
the the frustrations that say classical
liberals or conservatives have only go
to the traffic road right right found of
reinforcing one of those I know so so
exactly so I'm gonna I'm gonna move us
out of that watch watch what I'm gonna
do here watch the move the move is well
then what what can conservatives say
Christian conservatives or classical
liberals people that are more Liberty
minded in general what can they do right
now to make sure that they don't lose
those ideals because because we are
grieved that we are facing something
that is that is pretty bad and it's
pretty and it's not really rooted in in
reality or a consistent philosophical
outlook so I think there's a tendency
sometimes to go to our worst side to you
know fight the others and and what what
do you think we can do maybe from a
religious perspective you could give me
an answer on that yeah look I think I
think the first thing I'd say is that we
need to practice what we preach in the
sense that we shouldn't demonize others
demonize the ideas that's different I
think we should probably try and see
civility as not just meaning you know
Dave and John talk politely and I don't
criticize the way you hold your knife
and walk when you go public here but it
means much more that's not a knife it
was gonna get in here somehow one way or
another yeah I should tell you one of it
come back yeah we'll get to that I've
got several Crocodile Dundee questions
here don't worry I think we need to see
civility actually as a tough-minded
virtue that says picking up on the old
everyone beatriz whole idea that I may
disagree with you but I'll defend to the
death your right to say it it implies
two things I'll respect you enough to
say you have a right to put your ideas
on the table and then the ideas are the
issue because that's where we'll get the
best way forward it's not for me to
demonize you I don't like your ideas but
absolutely you got the right to put them
on the table let's stretch those out now
it's an unequal playing ground because
that's not the way the games being
played but I don't see any option and
even people like Gandy
kind of got that didn't he I mean it's
about forgiveness
that's something's washing out of our
culture yeah you know I don't know how
relationships ever work if we can't
forgive and I think we have to be
prepared to practice that it's okay I'm
sorry yeah I was offended but that
doesn't matter that's move on rather
than this perpetual I will carry the
offense to the grave mm-hmm and that's
the other great problem we've got in
that culture because we even if you can
try and forgive now you can't forget
because social media is stored up
absolutely everything so that's also the
interesting part is that the asymmetry
of the rules I think is what's becoming
harder and harder for conservatives so
for example Justin Trudeau can show up
in blackface I don't think most people
think he's a true racist by any stretch
he did something stupid it was you know
times change all of those things you
know we've had the governor here Ralph
Northam also you know blackface 30 years
ago but he's a Democrat and the point is
that they're both still in power well we
know if these were conservatives or
Republicans or whatever they would be
destroyed and then so then there's a
pageant well because of that then we see
the Conservatives going no we have to
destroy them too yeah and that's I think
that's the impulse that you're saying no
we have to fight that impulse yeah III
believe that's right I mean I think
there the other point would be to go to
the frankly the hypocrisy of it and
highlight that but to try and avoid
doing you know the triumphalism remember
the lessons when we stopped burning one
another at the stake at the heart of
this unique model of Western harmony
where we learn to live with one
another's and deepest differences was a
willingness to respect another person's
conscience and let them live truly to
that constants as long as they are not
damaging other people and I don't mean
by that occasionally offending people
this idea that you can't give a fence
and that is that that is a way to shut
down debate if ever there was and you
know if I'm honest about my life four
times in which I've grown up in the
times when I've been grossly offended
because somebody else has told me
something about me I haven't wanted to
hear yeah and I've had to grow out of it
you know that Jonathan Hart makes that
point you know we tell our kids we bring
them up to believe that
what doesn't kill you will make you
weaker he says actually if we need to
build resilience and when we get the
setbacks we've got to learn from and not
just be like a plastic cup that you drop
on the floor and recovers its shape we
actually need to be people when we've
had a setback who grow
he calls it antifragility and our
parents and grandparents believe that
and look at what the great generation is
you call them in this country went
through so is that just all then a
function of our success that our parent
your right our parents our grandparents
went through at grandparents
particularly at least in an American
context and because of that because of
that grit and fight that then they sort
of got us to unprecedented wealth a
growing middle class in the United
States and what happened well we got
participation trophies yeah other United
right and maybe it took I mean I grew up
with a father who had a horrendous
Second World War and I was born quite
late in his life and so I always lived
with a man had seen war he volunteered
hated it you know couldn't even talk of
it was almost killed in the campaign
against Rommel in the Western Desert and
that's shaped me but then I'm conscious
that I had a desire with my four
children to want a snowplow for them the
tendency was there I wanted to remove
every obstacle in a way that my father
didn't try for me he knew instinctively
but a few challenges were a good thing
for me and I knew that too but I had to
pull myself back was the instinct to all
the time was to make it soft and easy
and I think Jonathan Heights right it
doesn't work and he goes on to say that
we then encourage children to trust
their feelings your feelings are always
right we know that's not right
you have to think things through your
feelings must accord with reality it's
just dangerous to feel something's or I
feel that water would be nice and that
the signs saying that there are sharks
in their way of me having a good swim
you know and then the other one this
problem that gets to the heart of what
we're talking about we teach our
children that the dividing run between
good and bad is between people all that
bad life is a battle between good and
bad people it's a disaster it's a
disaster yeah most people on the other
side believe that they're good too
they may be wrong well not only that
we're all a mixture yeah and why can't
we go on a journey you write quite a bit
about how you've been on a journey
politically no well it's not a good
thing you know to think things through
and to learn from your mistakes Oh
forgive me it's not for me to say that
you've made mistakes or whatever but I
know I have absolutely made mistakes I
promise you yeah if you don't allowed to
know in the lexicon there are those who
hold the microphones in our society and
you see that with social media yeah the
thing we're talking about earlier you
make him a statements board up against
you 30 years later to keep you out of
public office when you might have grown
enormously as a human being and you
might have asked those that you hurt or
that you've misjudged oh but whatever
mistakes you made for forgiveness you
grow an enormous ear you've come to a
different place why should we not
respect that do you think oddly though
that the end of secularism leads us to
that place of unforgiveness do you think
that is sort of what you were talking
about earlier that if you remove all of
whatever traditional belief there is
that you will end up in a place that
will be so subjective that how would
forgiveness even make sense in that
world that sort of seems to me where
we're when you're sort of that at the
moment yeah I mean this is a great thing
that's all about power
everyone talks about power it's very
inadequate Douglas Murray says it if
you'd walk up to most people on the
street and say what most matters to you
most they won't take power they'll talk
about love that talk about relationship
is over but I think relationship in the
Western model draws an enormous amount
from our understanding of that thing
called the cross and that the central
message there was a death a life's
rendered four enemies out of love loving
your enemies we can't even love our
friends half the time yeah we need to
learn to love their enemies again which
is why I think I'm all for vigor in
debate I love what you do I love what
Jordan Peterson does I love what so I
mean this is a big part of the picture
you've got an enormous intellectual
vigor coming back into Western life and
that's tremendously encouraging and it's
an enormous privilege just to play a
tiny little bit you know I
in facilitating that with my own website
for example and so forth but I say this
is tremendously encouraging but we've
got to break the very model it's brought
us to us in the first boss to that place
in the first place which is the
rejection of the idea of the respect and
recognition of the Worth and dignity of
others are you amazed how this is a
truly worldwide phenomenon right now so
that's why I started the interview by
saying that you know you sent me this
email yeah three years ago and then you
know flash-forward basically two and a
half years and I'm in Australia and I'm
doing this event with you and everyone
in that room knew who I was
yeah and now most of them were there for
Jordan I can see that point but the
basic idea that what we're talking about
in America is the same thing you're
talking about in Australia you're the
same thing they're talking about France
they're talking about it in Mexico it's
not purely a Western society idea
anymore it's everywhere no no it is it
is indeed and a couple of observations
the wealthiest countries in particular
where it's been very easy for a long
time have lost sight I think a VOD of
suffering and suffering can be very
instrumental in determining character
and resilience and compassion for others
because you understand
we've got rid of the idea that suffering
you know is part of life we try to
pretend we can build perfect society
which is why people make unreal demands
on government mmm-hmm you know we don't
need gardening or none of that stuff we
don't need suffering anymore so mr.
congressman I expect you to solve every
you'll give me everything give me
everything and mr. congressman has been
unwise enough too often I if there's a
congressman listening police say I could
say exactly the same about what I was or
a senator in Australia we have senators
just like you do we have a wash minster
House of Representatives based on the
British House of Commons Senate is
modeled exactly on your Senate so we
call it a wash missus ah and we've just
got to break that cycle again and
rediscover some roots or or this is the
one you know can so but he doesn't
believe that the people who have gone
before them were less sir
but our culture now seems to think that
those who went before us have nothing to
teach us that is a fatal flaw mm-hmm
I've just been reading remarkable story
about Alexander Hamilton you know one of
the founding fathers who doesn't get a
lot of recognition because he died early
in a duel and he was a mixed grill of a
man he was a noble highly intelligent
imbued with what might be called
Christian principles who because of his
cleverness I think became vain and got
into silly disputes because of his
vanity and he died in a duel but you
read his writings and what have you as
he played his part the Federalist Papers
and so forth and establishing the land
of the free it's brilliant and to
dismiss the wisdom of the ages because
somehow were cleverer and they were
lesser no conservative short Eric's ever
ever adopt that line the wisdom we can
learn from Moses were mad to reject it
it's also wills cover a lot of it it
also strikes me as deeply personally
flawed so you asked me this when we were
in Australia but I've been the last year
I'd say I'm having a bit of a religious
awakening or at least a spiritual a
thing or a own awake and let's say about
belief in general the importance of
belief because the idea that somehow I
know something so much better or more
wittingly than than my parents or my
grandparents or my great-grandparents
all these people who lived through so
much more than I've lived through but
somehow I figured it out and it has
something to do with all of our
technology and everything else it's
actually absurd it's an erasure of the
people before you and it's a it feels
very weak and thin to me well I guess
that wasn't a question you're happy with
you're happy with my own answer there
we'll discuss that on your podcast how
about that all right how about let's
shift a little bit all together can you
just talk a little bit about what the an
American watching this should know about
Australia that we have no idea we you
know there's sort of this idea there's a
okay we know Crocodile Dundee we know
boomerangs and kangaroos and koalas okay
blah blah blah I absolutely for the 10
or so days that I was there I loved
every second every moment I was there I
thought
people were absolutely joyful and fun
and interesting now I know I'm
travelling in certain circles where I'm
gonna meet a certain type of person but
people that were coming up to me
everywhere and and and the weather was
great and just the events we did were
fantastic but what do we not know about
Australia besides you're a big
landlocked country yeah and there's and
there's kangaroos running down the
highways well it depends we talk well we
were when we were going from Canberra
attenders to see yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
you would
it's interesting question isn't it
because sometimes Americans I think
probably don't know a lot about
Australia no I truly don't think we do I
got lost in the middle of your country
once you were talking about knives this
is a true story
yeah and I had a little rented car which
I which had Missouri flights on the
girls in Kansas
looking for a good friend of mine who
lives right in the middle of Kansas I
got lost Sunday afternoon
pulled up outside a little weatherboard
house timber house and there's a lady
there with a pet raccoon on her shoulder
standing it welcome to America and three
children
yeah I said a girl about 15 and a boy
about 12 and a young girl ed and I
pulled up knives frustrated Dale you
know I don't about you but I can't when
I get lost
yeah and there's pre Babar found out
this is in the mid 90s I wind down the
window of this little car I say excuse
me ma'am I've got myself lost can you
show me where I am on this map well the
boy here he's about 12 he looks straight
up at his mother and he says hey mama
this dude talks just like Crocodile
Dundee
well she grabbed those kids that go head
and gathering her chicks and pull them
back out of dangers way and as if to say
you know he might have a knife he was
the good guy in the movie and she pulls
him around the front of the car check
what army the other one I think she's
going to look at the license plates
what's he season and all attention goes
out of her body says the kids it's
alright you can relax he's not from he's
not from Australia he's from Missouri
that's a strict Missouri accent he's guy
and she said is it I said actually your
boys ride on in from Australia and she
said did you drive you that's hilarious
yeah it's a true story I got to tell
George Bush that he laughed he said
anyway that's a hell of a drive because
that flight ain't easy
so you know the drives really took a
while the drives really give a
but what should we know about Australia
Australia was settled after America
became independent the traditional
wisdom is that the Brits were looking
for a new place to dump their prisoners
in fact it was nowhere near as simple as
that they knew there was a big land down
they wanted to put their flag on it
before the French Hilda Spanish or the
Russians Osetra sector etc and it the
same size as continental USA it was a
prison settlement interestingly the
convicts were of course were pretty wild
and there all sorts of Enlightenment and
Christian thinking went into how can we
turn these people around how can we
rehabilitate them there were those who
didn't want it I want to treat them like
slaves
mm-hmm interestingly enough the same
thing author said no slaves in the new
colony one of the first places in the
world when slavery was still legal right
throughout the British Empire and in
America it was banned in the new colony
huh from day one and then there was
there a big fight about that there there
no I don't think so it was really yeah
there wasn't and then there were those
who wanted to see it as a place of
rehabilitation and very sensitive issue
but arguments to about could we bring
enlighten and an education and salvation
to the Aboriginal people and of course
that became very vexed because we have
our own great difficulties in that area
yeah I do I wanted to ask about that
yeah and the amazing thing was that an
incredible effort was putting into
encouraging those convicts to marry and
many of them had illegitimate children
regulars their arrangements and what
emerged was there was known as the were
known as the currency lads and les is
the first generation of Australians born
on Australian soil turned out to be
model citizens and in some ways with
some parallels with your country they
built a nation now it's only six or
seven percent of Australian agricultural
land is high-quality for example a lot
of its desert so alerts the same size as
continental USA there's nowhere near as
productive
although we're very resource rich on the
other hand so still only 26 million
people much smaller than America that's
smaller than California and say yeah but
it's one of the so-called five eyes
countries America Britain Canada New
Zealand and Australia they share
everything there's an or
trust their democracies traditionally
we'd look to Britain until 1941 Pearl
Harbor Australian was in you know the
direct line of fire so to speak and an
unashamed pivot was made to seeing
America as the sort of senior friend to
whom we would relate and funnily enough
my mother married during the war on
American servicemen and lived in America
for a while it was one of those marriage
marriages born at war that didn't work
out she went back and married my father
had been home real childhood sweetheart
apparently so I did have some
connections with the place our own home
was modeled on a house that she lived in
and loved in America Wow yeah no little
bit of a link ease it yeah I think the
bonds are quite close the left in
Australia demonizes the republican
movement in Australia in America and I
think misunderstands the nature of the
Alliance but I think in the current
context Australians look on with concern
with the way the world is going and
recognize the importance of America's
strength I certainly do we are very
committed to the Alliance what do you
sense that there is something different
in terms of you know we've been talking
about the left a lot here I spoke to
several classical liberal organizations
in Australia I sense that liberalism in
and of itself was still kind of strong
in Australia now it's self selected
group of people I guess that I suppose
okay so am i no no no I know so right
you probably come here and I feel the
same thing and go oh it's not nearly as
bad but it depends who's inviting it
does um am i completely off in that no
not completely
I don't think but I think it's a bit
like your country when I look at America
and I love this country and I love its
can-do attitude and funnily enough when
I was a constituent I had about sixty
expat Americans who lived right in the
middle of my area and they bought the
cotton industry from the west coast of
America to Australia and they were
terrific citizens art I love their
can-do attitude you know they'd have a
go where
Australians can have a little bit of the
old British
you know the world is miserable yeah
they're out and living and the
government's had sorted out these
Americans I've learned a lot from them
to send out a positive attitude and
having a gut because they were I suppose
they were greatest generation products
really and it's very important to
understand that Australia didn't fight
for freedom it was given to us you know
a lot of Australians and say what the
heck are you talking about John think
about our past you know we had to forge
a life in it if you all that's true and
Australians have fought hard to defend
freedom but our Democratic traditions
and the institutions of freedom were you
know really bequeathed to us by the
British with a fair bit of input from
America so when the Australian
Constitution was being written we had
the best perceived wisdom from what I
would say was a great Protestant stream
of thinking filtering through the best
of the Enlightenment and the Australian
Constitution proven to be a very robust
document there's secured our freedoms we
don't have that same strength of
commitment that's still in this country
in certain strands of your public life
that's richly endowed with the deep
commitment to freedom that came out of
the independence struggles because it
was as I say we largely inherited it
we're very fortunate in that regard we'd
be prepared to defend it we didn't have
to fight to get it in the first place
this is particularly evident now
universities where there's a remarkable
lack of commitment to the Western Canon
to an understanding of our culture here
you still have great liberal arts
schools it's starting to Teeter here too
for sure we have we have major yeah
that's there and Australia was not as
strong however the the public debate has
become much more engaged and vigorous in
recent times and the recent election in
Australia was a very very very clear cut
that can the coalition which is a sort
of center-right grouping was not
expected to win a little bit of chaos
they chosen a new leader but Australians
were sick of the revolving door
leadership stuff but they decided this
leader actually represents the Australia
that we still have a great attachment to
and I think in a way that last election
two or three months ago was a
I hit the pause button it wasn't just
about the two parties economic policies
important as they were it was also
Australian saying we're getting bit sick
of being told what we can say and
therefore what we can think this stuff's
getting out of hand
and the other side's too keen on it for
our liking so are you enthuse then that
obviously the election basically went in
the direction that you want to do but
that's that that's seemingly also
happening in other parts of yours now
there's been a couple surprise elections
lately and even if you were to look at
the Canadian election which is obviously
not Europe although Trudeau won it's
going to be a minority government so
there is something when people are
looking for hope that's that's one of
the questions I get the most it's like I
have all these conversations and people
go alright Dave we can start
understanding the ideas now we can have
these conversations a little bit better
but where's the hope but the hope is
that there are there have been in the
last two or three years a couple
elections that have been sort of
center-right sort of sensible government
well I think that's right and um the
other thing you I think the great danger
there though is particularly in Europe I
think and I don't want to sound anti
environmentalism but I think what's
happened with the environment movement
has moved from the scientists and from
academia and from solid policy thinking
into the year or era of emotion and
populism itself and so you'll see
knee-jerk reactions which may instead of
helpfully decarbonizing the economy in
Europe wildy industrialized and then
with their levels of indebtedness and so
forth I'm not sure that's going to be
very helpful I mean the issue if you're
worried about climate remains frankly
India and China mm-hm
you know when you look at the cleanup
here right no matter what we do to clean
up here it's never enough no that's
right and you've made enormous progress
your emissions per heads and really
humid so they're quite a remarkable
story it doesn't get much credit but as
I understand it it's quite a story to
turn it back and ask you a question of
this you've been to Australia you are
with Jordan Peterson you must I don't
put words in your mouth but there are a
lot of young people turning out they
seem to be saying the empathy culture
doesn't really offer us what it promised
there has to be a better way was that
you're my main my main take was that
people were desperate and this this was
worldwide I definitely saw this in
Australia but everywhere
we went in Europe in the States and
Canada I saw the same thing which was
people desperately wanted to think about
their lives seriously that that was the
overriding theme so even the way I mean
I always reference this but I was amazed
it took me a couple shows to realize it
but suddenly I started on the amount of
people the way they dress at these shows
they're kind of dressed like us most of
you young guys and I've told the story
about how when I was in Sweden I was at
H&M and I was buying with just a
baseball cap and I'm standing on line
and the guy in front of me is telling
the cashier he's buying his first suit
because he's going to see Jordan
Peterson tonight and then the cashier
says I'm going to see Jordan Peters and
tonight and then he looked at me and he
goes you're Dave and it was like this is
crazy I'm on the street in Stockholm you
know I'm just at a store in Stockholm
and here are young people these guys
were 20 to 23 that all they wanted was
to just dumb you need to quote the book
right there they just wanted to get out
of the chaos so that that was the
overriding theme that I felt I think
there's an element to a lot of young
people feel rightly I have to say
insulted by the modern device yeah
that's that divides them into victims
and oppressors victims and victim makers
it's such a simplistic way of looking at
the world look both you and I could
invent a narrative it says we're victims
you know you've got a coffee I was
running from a kangaroo actually I was
running from a syphilitic koala I did
not know that the koalas all have
syphilis yeah it's very tragic yeah sad
story
chlamydia Clos is a committee in that
same sort of thing um both of us could
be painted as a present I've done things
that are wrong I know that but to divide
us in that way and to set us at enmity
this incredible desire in the West it
seems now to set women against men race
against race and generation against
generation mmm-hmm
now we've got this sort of despising of
adulthood we've got to listen to the
children some academic in Britain the
other day profit the children is from
six arms and have a vote
because I have wisdom that out also have
we taken leave of their senses oh but
you say we're all that war with one
another and I actually think a lot of
people saying I don't want a bit more
with every buddy and I know I'm not
always perfect and I've done the wrong
thing but basically I want to be a
decent person and I saw Jordan talk to
an audience of a thousand in Chatsworth
it's changed my outlook on things a lot
was an enormous encouraging in some ways
because there were a heap of young men
there and he was not a son you know he
walks under the stage they give him a
standing ovation now he's not a
celluloid hero he's I'm you know he's
not a global celebrity in a sporting
sense for anything he's there to say
you're not the people you ought to be
life can be tough and terrible go back
to your bedroom sort yourself out then
go out and be Noble and in empathy
culture at will or victimhood culture
it's not going to solve your problems
and they responded in other words he's
calling out their better angels at the
very time as he's telling them they're
not as good we all need to hear we are
not as good as we think we are or we as
bad as we think we are that's the great
irony isn't it we're lost in a lack of
self-esteem were over bloated with pride
we're such complex beings we've got it
all wrong that here are people looking
to say this isn't good enough and I want
to Bri build relationships I want to be
a responsible citizen
I'm enormous encouraged by that do you
think some of this is just the nature of
the fact that the internet exists yeah I
can put this video out and someone in
Australia can you wash it the same so
look the same moment someone in America
again and because of that that that's
great obviously at some level but the
the the negative of that is that we're
constantly exporting ideas good and bad
all the time we're commenting on
everything you know everything's going
faster than we can possibly imagine we
have no idea how this is all affecting
us and so perhaps for the first 20 years
let's say of the internet it it was good
it was bad it was causing tumult it was
fixing things that started revolutions
it sort of ended revolutions I mean all
of that and now maybe were sorted I mean
this would be the hopeful part is that
we're sort of maturing to the point that
some of the things you're talking about
it's like okay we can have that battle
of ideas forever
now maybe the the global conversation
has to be how do you how do you fix all
that I I think there's a lot of truth in
that
and and Neil Ferguson talks about how
the greatest parallel from the Internet
age is probably the printing press and
it resulted in a lot of chaos initially
but in the end of course it was
responsible for the spreading of wisdom
and of learning and of ability to if you
like share that transform the way that
we live and so this thing called you
know social media that in some ways it
means so disastrous and I think is
unquestionably helped spread the
victimhood culture by the way not just
to wealthy countries but even to a lot
of developing come and then and frankly
you know here we are on the west coast
of America I think Hollywood's had a bit
to do with this a friend of mine pointed
up look at the two Superman's the first
Superman was your simple pure a
childhood dream of the perfect all
capable powerful person the second one
still pretty effective and pretty
impressive but he had his shoes uh-huh
you know he was a victim uh-huh and
that spreads you see it goes everywhere
everybody watches Superman and so now to
be a Superman you you've got to have
issues too and we all have issues but
how you deal with them and so I do think
that yeah that this turbocharging of our
ability to take forward our best
thinking and highest ideals at the same
time as we can take forward the worst is
very lumpy
maybe it's encouraging that Mark
Zuckerberg has now come and said that he
will ensure that his platform does allow
for political debate and I'll say the
Democrats are very upset because they
think it gives Trump an advantage but
the fact that Mark Zuckerberg has now
seen that free speech is really
important for minorities and for the
oppressed he said that as I understand
it and he's right but surely is a
pointer that's encouraging do you think
I think it's basically encouraging and
my I mean you know my feelings on this I
would prefer that the government have
nothing to do with tech companies you
know like I know that there's high-level
conversations and we know that
there's ways that they're tied together
that maybe aren't as pure as as I would
like that or just they just are but
where do you fall on that actually
because when I was watching the
congressional hearings where they've
been grilling Zuckerberg over and over I
basically always been against
intervening and I would hope that
competition and human ingenuity can
solve some of these things and I'm
working on some of that myself
but I thought as I was watching AOC and
and some of the more far left Democrats
grill him I thought the people that are
calling for intervention are saying are
you that's those are the people you want
to have the power to yeah are you nuts
yeah so in a way so in a way they're
just outsourcing their tyranny to him
yeah well tell you exactly what I think
I hope America despise the common sense
and the leadership on this that Europe
hasn't because all of their emphasis is
emphasis as main on oh you're terrible
platform provided you clean up your act
or we will do it for you yeah and and of
course they don't have the protections
around speech that we have here that's
right yeah very important point everyone
forgets out of that America your defense
of free speech is robust second or not
that's it's the American Moakley so you
guys as great as the Australian
Constitution is there's nothing in the
Constitution that it directly enshrines
as well he's being right yeah it is Hugh
more than states it I think wouldn't be
the way to put it
yeah it's it's not and they haven't been
the amendments in their alien people
have been very reluctant to amend the
Constitution incredibly reluctant and
the mechanism set up to set the high bar
quite high as well so when you see these
laws the hate speech laws and then you
see social media crackdowns that happen
in Europe and then sometimes people's
Twitter accounts American people's
Twitter accounts get deleted because
they're violating a Pakistani blasphemy
law or something how worried are you
that some of that could you know get
over the ocean and get to you guys well
it's always a concern but to come back
to the essential point my great hope is
in America calls this right now see the
problem and where you get caught of
course is we do expect them to pull down
stuff that might be facilitating child
pedophilia or you know instructing kids
in how to make bombs mm-hmm and so they
have you got to draw a line somehow
between protecting free speech
and open debate and getting over this
issue of hate speech I mean it it's just
used to Club everything so how do you
how do you actually draw that line
though because I look up course those
two examples nobody wants child porn
online nobody wants Isis propaganda or
how to build a bomb
something like that that's why I'm so
encouraged by what yeah I understand
Zuckerberg said surely in this country
if we can just get above the personal
and the acrimony and appealed of a
better angels with America's tradition
of commitment to freedom you get people
to do what Mark Zuckerberg stunts and
let's sit down and talk about this
properly and maturely so we can protect
robust free debate at the same time as
we deny oxygen to things that are truly
dangerous because the free exchange of
ideas even if many of them are offensive
builds freedom there's a sharp
difference we know that let the Sun
Shine in on bad ideas don't put some
underground different matter altogether
when you're talking about facilitating
evil people who are intentionally going
out to blow people up or or to subject
them to sexual harassment damage are you
hopeful would you say that your how
would you describe your general outlook
on life it's a race against time and as
I would say as I would say say the world
has changed dramatically in strategic
terms as well we're very conscious of
that way we live and so the idea that
somehow other democracies won out the
Frances on their idea end of
history that we'll all be free open
democratic capitalist societies led by
America is really over already and it
happened very quickly in the world is
now a center of competing power
constellations I remain hopeful that
America because of its pivotal role it
was an interesting comment made in the
Australian Parliament by Tony Blair said
sometimes we like to criticize our
American cousins but the realities that
no great global challenge can be managed
without their full involvement so I
remain hopeful and America will discover
rediscover a higher degree of unity and
purpose for the sake of humanity if I
can make that appeal to Americans I put
aside some of this terrible polarization
I think Arthur Brooks now talks about
it's not just anger it's an anger plus
disgust equaling contempt and that
destroys relationships we've got to end
this business where we're tearing
ourselves apart not focusing on our
common common citizenry citizenship and
we need to do that globally as well the
leadership role is really important
because as I say I think it is a race
anything could go wrong strategically
globally well in that case people who
love freedom led by the Americans will
be critical and whether the world breaks
the current stalling of the opening up
of democratic freedoms that followed the
further falling the Berlin Wall or
whether it retreats and more and more
countries see through the restrictions
on freedom the whining back of the
progress that was being made
democratically and then the other side
of you know the foundational issue is
we've got to avoid anything ourselves
out from within at the same time as it's
a race against making sure we're ready
to defend freedom globally I don't think
it's sort of laid out in Missouri at all
but there are good people everywhere I
think who see the dangers and are
stepping up let's hope they're in time
that's a solid closing statement my
friend and you've been doing this for a
long time from the political side and
now you're doing it with with all the
conversations that you're having and as
you mentioned you had many of the people
that their books are right here have
been on your show it's been a pleasure
now we're gonna flip the script and are
you gonna sit in this chair well let it
be will say give me a position the
feeling of great power and influence
there you go all right we're gonna flip
the script in a moment and I'll be doing
conversations with John and for more on
John you can go to John Anderson net a
you if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell